[Music]
we do know that Donald Trump senior has
lied throughout this investigation this
goes to the heart of everything we've
been talking about for the last couple
of years the collusion has and the
cover-up I also think there's a very
strong argument to be made that this is
a high crime or misdemeanor for which
impeachment may be a possibility
president's tweet couldn't have been
scripted better if it was written by
Putin himself Donald Trump is going
there to meet with his handler the
Republican Party has surrendered to
Russia well just some of the reporting
leading up to the Muller report was
quite wide off the mark senior political
analyst Brit Hume is here with some
lessons learns learned perhaps it's been
a long year and 10 months Brit it has
indeed and if you think about it Brett
this investigation actually goes back to
the middle of 2016 so it's been going on
for quite a long time and this endless
speculation about it indeed the
accusations about it that came out of
many mouths on cable television and in
the in the public prints the the list of
people who got it wrong is really quite
extensive and you know to include many
news organizations that got the prospect
of Donald Trump being elected in the
first place badly wrong and seemed not
to learn very much from that one hopes
and expects perhaps that after this
debacle and that's exactly what it is
and the worst journalistic two buckle of
my lifetime that there'll be some
serious soul-searching unfortunately so
far Brett I'm not seeing a lot of it I
noticed that a couple of our cable news
competitors have moved kind of
seamlessly onto speculation about
obstruction of justice now following as
they so often seem to do the democratic
party script remarkable you think it was
worse than the Iraq WMD coverage I do
because I think the Iraq WMD coverage
was really basically driven by an
intelligence failure that was not a
failure by journalists and you know
people believed Saddam Hussein had WMD
because you know every intelligence
service and the earth basically thought
the same thing every voice in Congress
said the same thing
and you know and he and he never really
quite denied it in fact he behaved as if
he had them all along and so I think
that you know so reporters and reporters
mostly reported what officials were
saying about it
the officials turned out to be wrong
because the intelligence was wrong a lot
of what we saw here was a lot of a lot
of what we saw he was reporting yeah you
had so many anonymous sources flying all
kinds of things it seemed a flagpole
every day in different papers and then
you had former intelligence officials
who were hired by cable outlets like the
former CIA director Brennan the former
National Intelligence director clapper
who were saying extraordinary things on
the air yeah Brennan and apparently said
something this morning to the effect
that well maybe he was misinformed and
you know this didn't turn out quite the
way he expected it to well I guess and
you know those guys have a lot to answer
for too it seems to me and so do the
news organizations that credulous Lee
put on the air what they had to say over
and over and over again was route really
any evidentiary support it was really
quite remarkable bread the last thing
quickly
speaking of over and over and over again
how about this news about Michael
avenatti after he appeared over and over
and over again on some of those channels
he certainly did bread he was by one
count he was on CNN and MSNBC 108 times
between March and May of last year and
he was being taken seriously on the air
as a presidential candidate and you were
thought that a guy like this with the
dodgy accusations that he made and and
so on that somebody in those
organizations would have smelled a rat
and thought you know maybe we shouldn't
be publicizing this guy maybe we
shouldn't be having this guy on all the
time but he had one thing that they
wanted and that was he was very much
antitrump
and they were too and the result was
what you see another embarrassment to
the media Brett as always thank you that